i am sweating zendaya and tom holland
just
can't stay away from each other i just
feel very lucky
e.t has new details on how the
spider-man co-stars spent their fourth
of july weekend together
an eyewitness tells us the actors
holidayed in santa barbara
spotting the couple on saturday as they
had dinner together at a casual
restaurant
the source says quote they walked in
together sat down
and enjoyed a low-key dinner just the
beginning of this really adorable
romance that we're watching kind of
bloom on camera the following day
zendaya and tom ate lunch poolside at
their hotel
where they were also seen laughing as
they took up mini golf
with zendaya taking cute photos of tom
throughout the game
it's almost like he should be the source
adds the young stars
quote seemed comfortable with each other
and looked super sweet
and happy to be relaxing on vacation
zendaya and tom have been enjoying time
on the west coast for a while
now the pair was also seen in los
angeles last week where they were
photographed kissing
while sitting in traffic have you found
that it's hard a day in hollywood so at
such a young age
of course it is i mean it's hard today
at any age i mean
it doesn't matter you know where you are
either i mean it's just hard to date in
general
and if you remember dating rumors with
these two first began circulating a few
years ago
during the actor's worldwide press tour
for spider-man homecoming in 2017.
i had this like really nice leather
jacket and he was like running out of
clothes
on the press tour he was like oh i
really like this jacket i was like well
try it on and it fit him and he was like
oh i'ma take it right back thank you for
reminding me because i need to let him
know
he needs to get that sent back to me but
zendaya shut down the romance
speculation at the time when she simply
called tom
one of her best friends and a great dude
there gets nervous there you go that's
true you know everybody has to ruin your
and that august zendaya told et she
wasn't fazed by the dating rumors
i mean it happens all the time and of
course you know we we expected it
it comes with the territory both stars
have been linked to other people in the
years since
last year tom dated actress nadia parks
for a time
even making their relationship instagram
official
sharing this pic with his fans around
the same
time zendaya was seen getting close with
euphoria co-star jacob elordi
she's brilliant you know she's beautiful
and she's a she's a wonderful performer
and she just
captains the ship perfectly and now
years later
neither zendaya or tom have never
officially confirmed their past or
present relationship status
give me one thing that i've actually
spoiled the last
movie title
in february the actors helped reveal the
official title for the web slinger's
next movie
spider-man no way home out in december
in 2019 the pair told et just how much
fun they have on set
there's the most amazing footage of you
and it's spiderman
taking a drink on set yeah it's an
interesting contraption to say the least
basically my eyes in my mask
they clip off they come off because
they're glass and and
obviously the suit is is fabric and they
need to clip in
and what i can do is i can take my left
one out and there's a little like
thing that i pull out and then i put a
um
a tube a squeezy tube down into my mouth
and then i can drink from a
bottle but what i found out now is that
this video of you doing that in new york
and this little kid just like remember
the store
oh yeah yeah in a store there's this
little kid behind him just watching him
drink from his eye
like you're ruining what is happening